hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar achieving operational excellence
in clinical chemistry through innovative
assay design and technology i'm susie
valdez of labyrinths and i will be your
moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab roots and brought to you by abbott
to learn more visit them at core
laboratory dot abbott
now we encourage you to participate
today by submitting any questions you
might have during this presentation to
do so simply type them into the q a
ask a question box and click send we'll
answer as many questions as we have time
for at the end of this presentation you
may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing this presentation this
webinar is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education window
at the bottom of your screen
to obtain those credits i'd now like to
welcome our speaker dr marvin berman a
manager of scientific services at abbott
core diagnostics dr berman welcome you
may now begin your presentation sir
thank you
uh just give a little background about
myself uh i have city years of
experience at avid labs i've held a
number of positions that look at the
product life cycle
i've got expertise in developing and
supporting new products as well as spec
setting and product investigations
i have expertise in clinical chemistry
and
immunoassays and i'm the contact for
diabetes and metabolic syndrome disease
the objective learning objectives today
for decades clinical chemistry has been
a key discipline in lab medicine and
comprises the majority of the workload
in the core lab
in this one hour webinar participants
will learn how recent innovations in
nasa design
analytical technologies and
instrumentation are still being made and
are helping to deliver high quality
results and take laboratory operational
excellence to the next level
abbott has a great history of innovative
design in diagnostics
started with manual assays in the early
60s
the first immunoassay for hbv and hiv
we are well known for our blood
screening assays
we have gone into automated instrument
systems like molecular and molecular
diagnostics our amino acid and conchem
systems
and real-time pcr and elini is our next
generation of information those systems
as well abbott has a great history
in uh critical chemistry sorry about
that um
we have uh
been developing
instruments from the 70s onward uh
a lot of we're well known for our
architect platform and now we have we
are placing our lindy instruments
for amino assay and clint chem
how does abbott help
the labs we have more than 40 years of
expertise in clinical chemistry
and we provide personalized solutions to
give you the power to address the
challenges of facing your lab
we have assays with great performance
we maximize throughput in a very compact
footprint
we are we provide
confidence through our thoughtful design
and we are always responding to changing
needs of the laboratorium
what is sigma strong sigma strong is
avid's new approach to clinical
chemistry where we are bringing assay
formulation
improvements and continuing to leverage
our innovative technologies deliver
confidence in six sigma clinical
chemistry results which i'll go over in
the
following slides essay private
activities through assay and system
design and leading to a total value of
ownership improvements
enabling labs to achieve sustained
operational excellence
i'll go over assay designs and impact on
operational productivity
quality is essential in the clinical
chemistry
labs
the challenge labs need to provide
reliable high quality results to support
clinician decision making how can we
address that challenge asset parameters
align to the latest clsi guidelines and
delivering six sigma analytical quality
uh
the challenge is to simplify the
clinical chemistry evaluation process
with transparent assay performance
specifications
cosi guidelines are protocols that are
developed from input from manufacturers
clinical labs regulatory agencies
and avid uses those guidelines to ensure
that our products meet not only our
manufacturing specs but the needs of the
clinical labs
dclsi guidelines are harmonized so that
whether you go to abbott or another
vendor
you can be assured of the performance
meaning the clinical lab if you're
following these guidelines
for example uh sensitivity guideline ep
1782 which is known as llb lodlq
provides guidance on three metrics limit
of blank or llb
limit of detection which measures uh lob
in the test replicate of a known sample
with a low concentration of analyte and
llq or limit of quantitation which is
the lowest concentration that can be
detected based on a target value
for both bias and precision
the highlights of this
csi guideline is that allows for
defining llq by precision only or by
total error
if you're using less than four reagent
lots you can calculate
your sensitivity llb d and q by
instrument and lot and you can take the
worst case
testing usually has three reagent lots
and two instruments
to really get the performance of your
product
and allows extreme studentized deviation
tests to identify potential
outliers as i said testing is six
instruments three six instrument reagent
lot combinations over three days
you have a zero analyte sample of 60
reps and you have low analyte samples to
provide 60 positive
reps
data analysis for llb or luna blank is
the 95 percentile of the zero analyte
concentration
lod or limited detection is your
eliminate blank and the standard
deviation of your positive results
uh llq limit of quantization is the
estimated total error
and it's also the higher of the limit of
detection or lowest concentration in
which the total error or percent total
error is meant or the lowest
concentration of which precision is met
or the lowest concentration which bias
and precision are met independently
acceptable modifications you can have
fewer zero or low analyte samples but
you must test more replicas
another
guideline is ep34 if you look at the
labeling of manufacturers it's very
difficult to understand the range
some call it an assay range some call it
a calibration range some call it a
reportable range there are multiple
names as you can see in this slide
ep34 tries to
is harmonizing that to give you a
measuring interval and a portable
interval and i'll go into more detail on
that in the next slide
the analytical measuring interval or ami
is the range of what specimen
concentrations are measured within the
medical and lab needs for accuracy with
no dilution
concentration or other pre-treatment
that is not part of the standard or
routine measurement process inclusive
evolutions are treatments that need to
that need no user intervention
extended measuring interval is or emi is
the range with concentrations are
measured with appropriate accuracy by
diluting the specimen before taking a
measurement with the developed
measurement process
and the reportable interval or ri is the
range that includes the analytical
measuring interval and the extended
measuring interval but also extends to
the lower limit of detection lod
so you can see in the figure below
that the ami goes from the
lower limit of quantitation to the upper
limit of quantitation
the extended measuring interval goes
from the upper limit of quantitation to
the upper limit of
quantitation
and the portable interval encompasses
both the ami and the emi and this lower
limit of detection
so csi allows harmonization across
different uh vendors to provide a
consistent and clear definition of assay
performance characteristics
six sigma quality is an analytical
quality
test which is defined by accuracy
precision and a quality specification
such as
such as total allowable error for that
analyte
you can see the formula
on the right here that sigma equals
total allowable error minus the bias
divided by the precision cv or sd
you have a certain target for your
analyte
the precision of the
instrument to measure the analyte is the
spread here the bias is how far are you
from the target and from that you can
calculate the number of defects or a
sigma level
one sigma means you have as high as uh
over almost 700 000 defects per million
which is deemed an accessible
performance
three sigma is 67 000 defects per
million which is considered marginal
performance and six sigma where you want
to be is only 3.4
million defects per million and it's
considered world-class
so
knowing your sigma kind of gives gives
you a better sense of the performance of
your product
why is that important
it's important because it evaluates your
your specification of total allowable
error against your bias and precision
performance
these this just shows that using this
equation you can calculate your bias
as well
there's a predefined c
total allowable error
and your observed bias and cv
your sigma value can be determined
why is that important
on the graph here you have accuracy plot
against precision
if you have poor precision and poor
accuracy you're going to be well off
your target
if you have poor precision but good
accuracy you'll be you'll be close to
your target but you're going to be
you're going to have a wide distribution
if you have poor accuracy but good
precision your your values are going to
be very tight but you're going to be off
target and where you want to be is in
this grid here where you have good
accuracy and good precision
to have high confidence that you're
delivering
a a good response
this slide here shows that uh
you cannot that your
limits for total allowable error in this
case uh from clia are always changing
and they're not they're getting tighter
so the better sigma performance you have
the better off you're going to meet be
able to meet
total allowable errors in the future as
these limits are only going to get
tighter
this is some uh
quality data from westgard
where he pulled uh
qc data from participating around the
world to assess uh different uh
assays from different uh competitor
systems and you can see
uh in this
company here there's a widespread
performance of their products it's
better in this this company where you
have more products in the six sigma
range and thick in green
and
less in
the
two sigma range and here is where you
want to be with a product that has a lot
of different products in the three to
six sigma range
again here's another uh
example from westgard
where he chose abbott lindy assay
against atelica and copis for a wide
variety of assays and determining if
they're uh in the range of two to six
went to six sigma and you can see
plotted here the number of six sigma
assays for the different assays
and you want to have a platform that has
a high number of assays in the three to
six sigma range
this is an example of a
abbott six sigma strong assay for album
bcg
uh as you can see has good uh accuracy
four per eight percent bias against the
target of 3.72
it has
a good precision of 1.4 percent
against a total
allowable error
uh goal of 14 percent
it has a percent total alveolar 7.6 and
a sigma greater than six
and so it's in the six sigma range of
world class
now some of the other sigma strong
assets perform
here's again album bcg
uh another album bcp mlas cholesterol
and total protein and you can see all
these assays are six sigma or greater
why is it important to have a six sigma
assay you can see that
the westgard rules
for
higher sigma assays
are better than for a low sigma essay so
over here you can see a six sigma assay
and here you can see a three sigma assay
six sigma assay quality requires only
one control rule with two control levels
where
an assay was less than four requires an
8x rule with four quality control
measures in each of two runs
so would you rather run
two control levels or multiple controls
what is the impact on six sigma metrics
on a on a particular lab here's an
example of a lab
where
they have uh
91 reduction in false qc rejection after
implementing six sigma quality and
uh 91 percent of labor cost savings
uh when they use assays with greater
signal performance
six signal quality goes beyond the lab
you get decreased errors resulting in
consistent delivery of accurate test
results improved turnaround time leading
to better patient care better physician
and patient satisfaction
so all round
satisfaction not only for the lab but
for
the patient as well
i'll talk a little bit about assay
productivity through avid
assay and system design
the challenge of the lab you have many
manual processes that have
hamper efficiency
increased risk of error and
inconsistency
how to address that challenge
use assays and systems that utilize
innovative technologies to enable
streamlined workflows reduce hidden
costs and improve efficiency
abbott offers unique and proven
technologies
uh
an ict module which provides a simple
single simple uh to install integrated
chip
for measuring the electrolyte sodium
potassium and chloride
with cvs of less than one percent and
each module delivers multiple tests
and
automated maintenance is provided
a lot of bubble detection
to ensure
that samples don't have bubbles or form
and clots which could affect sample
integrity or aspiration of the sample
smartwatch technology which prevents
clinically significant sample to sample
carryover and eliminates the need for
additional consumables
flex rate technology extends the linear
ranges of enzyme assays for better first
time results and fewer repeats
and sample interference indices for
pre-analytical measurements
of
hemolysis victoris and leupemia to
reduce
the risk of reporting incorrect results
due to interferences and i'll go with a
little bit more detail on these in the
next slides
the ict module is an integrated chip
it saves cost due to reduce operator
interventions and reduce sample volume
requirements as i mentioned you can get
60 000 determinations per module less
than one percent cd automated
maintenance you can report
one or all electrolytes with each
sampling of the sample so you don't have
to do
a separate set simple
separate testing for potassium chloride
and sodium you get all those metrics at
the same time from one sample
uh this slide just shows some of the
performance metrics you can see that
tooth type equivalency across lithium
heparin sodium heparin lithium heparin
it was separated to the serum separator
tubes performance is
equivalent as well
endogenous interference testing for
icterious
hemolytic and lupic set samples were all
well
hemolysis for potassium was a little bit
high but that's because red blood cells
contain potassium and any
hemolysis will
result in the release of internal
potassium
sample enrage and aspiration
our systems offered liquid level sensing
and bubble and clot detection
prefer pressure differential technology
accurately distinguishes between a
normal sample a bubble and a clot
lining software notifies the operator
while the instrument attempts to remove
a clot and clear the probe and it
reduces the risk of reporting incorrect
results so the software evaluates every
sample
this is a graph of a normal sample and
this is a graph of a sample that has a
clock and the system can
detect this difference
and reject the sound and flag a sample
that has a clock
sample carryover avid smartwatch
technology and serves minimum sample to
sample carryover
smartwatch provides an additional wash
process using detergents and acid and
alkaline solutions optimized and
automatically performed by the system as
needed for reagent probes sample probes
and cuvettes to reduce interference from
carryover
the configuration of the smartwatch
parameters is determined by studies that
looked at potential carryover between
specific assay combinations avid has
established that carryover
specifications meet or exceed the bias
or total allow error requirements for
each assay these specifications follow
internationally recognized criteria from
clia
ncab
the
nkdp
and several others are shown here
avid chemistry systems also have an
optimum sampling sequence feature which
automatically determines the sampling
sequence so as to minimize the
consecutive measurements of assays
configured as smartwatch pairs
this just shows how we do these studies
you have a sample with the
analyte that could potentially cause
it could
potentially cause carryover followed by
a low concentration sample
uh
you look at the threshold
of the carryover
and you can determine
uh that the cat doesn't carry or meet
uh the specifications that you set to to
ensure that no carryover occurs in this
case the cutoff for carryover was .022
and you can see that added abbott's arc
technology systems
provide carryover less than 0.1 part per
million and it shows some other systems
as a comparison
what is the impact of the smartwatch
having smartwatch technology no
clinically significant carryover and
ensures confidence and results that
influence patient care it means no need
for pipetting tips or alcotting to avoid
carryover contamination in samples
no need to run all immunoassays first to
avoid carryover in the chemistry systems
and no need for carryover evasion
protocols that could lead to
inconsistent turnaround times
uh
one technology unique technology that
abbott offers is called flex rate it's
an avid technology that extends the
readable range of selected clinical
chemistry enzyme assays by using two
absorbance retime windows
a normal read window shown on the right
and green and an area read window showed
on the right in orange
flux rate allows extending the linearity
of chemistry enzyme assays by as i said
using these two absorbance retime
windows it allows you to maintain an
analytical performance it's automated so
the operator doesn't need to be involved
it increases the lab efficiency by
getting results in the first pass and
it's a cost savings as well as time
saving for better cost effectiveness
so as you can see
in green is a normal response that is
linear in the green grid window and so
it reports a result
however sometimes your enzyme substrate
can be depleted resulting in a flat
response in the main read window so
rather than requiring you to
rerun the sample
the system defaults to a newer read time
and where your
your response is linear and it can
calculate a result on that sample
without needing to re-test
here's just showing performance of some
of our enzyme assays and you can see
they all have
good slopes
high
upper limit of detection
good lower limit of detection
and
you can see that they perform
very well architect versus elementary
platforms
hil interferences what is that
it's a it's a automated
method on our systems that allows you to
measure
h index i index and l index h standing
for hemolysis i for
picteric or bilirubin and l for leukemia
as you can see
the detection of the different
illnesses
hemolysis in red has specific absorbance
at 415 540 and 570 that can be measured
bilirubin in yellow can be uh detected
at 400 and 540 and lopimia which is a
little bit hard to see here in this
slide is over a wide range
by using
the index values
and
we can estimate
the potential for a sample to interfere
these indices cannot be used for
determining actual concentrations but
gives a good estimate of hemoglobin
bilirubin and triglyceride
abbott has
established
qualitative scores of 1 to 4 as well as
quantitative scores for each of the
indexes h i and l in conventional units
and s i international units
so for example an h index score of 4
means that the sample has greater than
500 makes per deciliter of hemoglobin
an i index score of 2 indicates
bilirubin concentration estimates of
between 4 to 10 migs per deciliter
using these scores in combination with
the package insert tells you if a sample
could potentially interfere in that
particular assay
and avid provides these package insert
indices
in
easy to read brochure for all of its
products
conclusions
there are many considerations for assay
system design commutability correlation
across platforms standardization of
assays expected values and caliper or
pediatric reference ranges
customer and key expert engagement early
adopter data customer data and support
scientific collaboration
quality avenues of modernized
expectations consistent ifus driven by
csi guidance and other agencies
stigma levels
and accuracy tied to external standards
critical menu items like
hva1c drugs of abuse therapeutic drug
monitoring that differentiate
performance and function
efficiency error proof designs
always on load on the fly
on board materials with high capacity
reagents cows and controls lab
utilization small footprint stable
configurations
lab personnel simple to use instruments
and high load capacities
abbott can deliver values for innovative
technology and assay design here is a
case study
from saint francis hospital that has
been using
the avid products
they've noticed that
89
of their ass at the avid assays were
performing at five sigma or better
they saw cross platform commutability
with an average correlation coefficient
of 0.994
for 32 of the clinton assays and 0.995
for 13 of their immunoassays
operational excellence was observed by a
29
increase in test per square foot
76 reduction in manual maintenance time
and the 96 percent
stack turnaround time goal achieved for
three critical panel assets
as well labs across the globe have
achieved measurable performance
healthcare performance with the avid
could chem uh
assays
here's from clemenzo clemenzo medical
center
resource utilization
33 percent fewer
staff required during uh primary shifts
for routine operation
75 less overtime expense they've seen
operational excellence by limiting uh
manual sample prep for tests ensuring
requiring pre-treatment
and a saving of 15.5 weeks of time and a
cost savings of 40
decreased due to
less quality control consumption
thank you for allowing me to
present to you and if there's any
questions i can take them now
thank you
and thank you dr berman for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live q a portion of our
webinar if you have any questions you
want to ask please do so now just click
on that ask a question box located on
the far left of your screen and we'll
answer as many questions as we have time
for
it looks like we already have some great
questions coming in
dr berman our first question will using
hil on the alinity system slowed down
the throughput of testing
uh
no not really there are publications
already out there showing that using
automated systems whether it's from the
habit or somebody else
do not take a lot of time and hardly
impact your throughput
at all but are very important as a
pre-analytical check of the sample to
ensure
that
you're not getting interference from
hemolysis leukemia or taric samples
thank you thank you so much and how
would
someone determine the precision and bias
of the assay on a system to determine
the sigma
matrix uh
there's there's no one way to do it you
know one way is not more preferential
than the other
what is good is what is important is to
get a good estimate whether that's
running multiple instruments or multiple
days
or months multiple samples to get an
estimate of your precision or accuracy
we recommend using using an external
standard like a nist standard
to measure accuracy that way it's
commutable across different competitor
systems and we recommend at least a
five-day precision study to get a good
estimate
precision across at least one or two
instruments
thank you and thank you and i want to
thank our audience for these great
questions coming in
dr berman our next audience member says
why would one want to use a standard
instead of calibrator material to assess
accuracy of a method
there's nothing wrong with using a
calibrator material if you're on the
same system
but
because you're calibrating with that
material you may be a little bit
you may not get as accurate a picture of
your accuracy as you would like by using
an external standard that has been
certified as truth
or a
real
exact reference material you can get a
measure of that uh material not only on
your system but other systems as well as
knowing it's independent of your
calibration and it's giving a true
measure of accuracy on your system
thank you
thank you so much and we have one more
question coming in dr burnham why does
competitor labeling sometimes have
better limit of detection sensitivity
than abbott products
that's a good question uh
if they're following clsi guidelines for
uh
how you determine limited blank limited
detection and limit of quantitation
the act the comparison should be uh
uh very simple to do however
a lot of times uh the laban will say a
limit of a detection but if you look how
they're actually determining limit of
detection they were actually doing a
blank so you want to use a manufacturer
that is following the latest csi
guidelines so that you can compare the
results that you're seeing on one
platform against another platform and
using abbott's
products you can be assured that they
are following the latest cfi guidelines
thank you
dr berman thank you for your
presentation today would you like to
provide any closing remarks before we go
uh well uh i hope i've given you a good
sense of
what sigma metrics are and why they're
useful to understand how your product is
performing against different competitors
systems so that you know you are picking
the best product available as well uh if
there's additional questions that you
have please forward them to us and
our avid representative will be more
than happy to
address your questions or send them up
to us
thank you
and thank you again dr berman for your
time today and for your important
research and i also want to thank
labruts and our sponsor abbott for
underwriting today's educational webcast
and before we go i want to thank our
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by our speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration and this webcast
can be viewed on demand library to alert
you via email when it's available for
replay we encourage you to share that
email with your colleagues who may have
missed today's live event until next
time take care everyone bye